cette voiture de luxe jet ski et
exercice physique il ya comme un air de
clips de rap dans cette vidéo des
millions de vues et beaucoup de
commentaires d'internautes ravis et
d'autres beaucoup plus dubitatif
derrière leur écran sans juger c'est
quoi le concept du truc ou carrément
ironique bravo d'être riche ça valait
bien une vidéo vrai ou faux on a donné
le nom de donald trump a une espèce de
blé roux
[Musique]
c'est vrai et faux
mais on a donné son nom à une mite ouais
elle s'appelle l'année opale pas donald
trump et car elle possède des petites
écailles jaune sur la tête
ont rappelé aux chercheurs canadiens qui
l'a découverte la coiffure de l'ancien
président américain
être stylée oui mais dans un genre
différent et pour aller voir les
millions 2 au cinéma la tendance eux
gentle mignon déferlent dans les salles
et se répand sur les réseaux sociaux
plusieurs vidéos montrent des groupes de
jeunes hommes débarqué en costumes aux
séances du film d'animation pour enfants
le pourquoi du mouvement n'est pas bien
clair mais le concept semble séduire
beaucoup de spectateurs dans les pays où
le film est déjà sorti la tour eiffel
va-t-elle tomber le magazine affirme
avoir consulté plusieurs rapports concié
confidentiel de la scène la société qui
exploite la tour eiffel et la dame de
fer serai rongé par la rouille c'est
bien simple confié un cadre à
l'hebdomadaire si gustave eiffel visiter
les lieux aujourd'hui il aurait une
syncope
c'est de toute beauté
blonde heures
c'est vrai que c'est de toute beauté la
blondeur je sais pas ça alors depuis sa
création la tour eiffel a bien entendu
été repentent une vingtaine de fois mais
sans grandes précautions en fait on a un
peu accumulé les couches et la peinture
ne tient plus à se craquelle de partout
ça s'écaille pour un spécialiste ces
opérations de cache misère sont une
hérésie alors vous qui connaissez bien
lieu du bâtiment a en tout cas paula que
conseillent les professionnels eh bien
il faut décaper entièrement la mettre à
nu et repeindre à 9
ce serait une première mondiale
une cérémonie d'ouverture des jeux
olympiques de paris en 2024 sur la scène
six kilomètres du pont d'austerlitz au
pont de iéna 160 bateaux pour les
délégations et les chefs d'état six cent
mille spectateurs
vous habitez près de bordeaux à queyrac
et alors vous avez été champion
départemental d'aquabike ouimet a mis
moins de piscines et en vélo et je vous
montre un spectacle grandiose mais
difficilement sécurisable
d'ouverture et le stade de france plus
un semis parce que c'est une cérémonie à
ciel ouvert avec 14 km 12 km de voies de
berges a sécurisé avec des forces de
sécurité gendarmerie police nationale
armée qui vont être forcément en nombre
insuffisant et qui vont mobiliser tout
ce que la france compte 2 comme forces
de sécurité alors il est tout petit peu
juste pour moi non non non faut me va
et leurs déguisements possibles et
imaginables
et voilà effectivement on a fière allure
avec avec ce genre de de casque est ce
qu'on ferait pas une petite
démonstration
je veux savoir déjà faut que l'otan soit
consentant
vinci de la trop tôt à 7 jours manquons
daguise yoel quand il a des idées
idiotes elles sont probables
des inondations répétées de forte
sécheresse et des feux de forêt
dévastent de la sûreté qui a maintenant
comment dire une intempérie sur la
planète ces deux changements climatiques
donc ce que possible d'ailleurs être que
la chute d'un glacier et semer les jeux
mais b et le goût moi j'écris l'autre
jour quelqu'un qui m'a dit que le climat
toujours changer autres à gervais oui ou
non il expliquait que le climat a tout
changé je peux rentrer dans cette
polémique
il est très attaché
est vraiment hyper attaché
me franck fife non non non c'est
l'avocat y voit
le jour j est john wayne marshall aux
super riches avaient
tous dit il n'est jamais ridicule ça qui
est formidable
c'est les caennais ont
fait des câlins oui mettez les capotes
pas d'enfants allez bonne soirée
la coupe et la coupe elle se cache mois